真正赚钱的事不是写在新发力的事
是那些没有写在新发力的事
我们90%以上的人对这个事的利益都是错的
更可怕的是还不资资
那我想想这条视频该怎么讲
有难度
我常试的去表述一下
你可能需要多思考一下
注意啊我可不是让你去做违法的事
恰恰相反我是告诉你天万不要做违法乱期的事
好我们开始了
第一个
你认为这个世界是公平的吗
我告诉你一定是不公平的
比如说玩一款游戏这个游戏里边有三种角色
哪三种呢
游戏规则的遵守者
游戏规则的解释权游戏
解释权的人
和游戏规则的制定则
那么
你首先哪一种
然后我们在
在说这个世界上长一点的两种游戏
一种游戏叫成帮游戏
这个游戏里边这个成帮都已经建设好了
对吧
规则都是有的
现在有一块地大家都在争
谁会强到这块地
很女人说会是
最有实力的
不是
可能是最懂游戏规则的人
或者是
最善用
最善于另一种游戏规则的人
或者是对游戏规则有解释权的人
或者是甚至可以修改游戏规则的人
那还有一种游戏呢
我就不问你属于哪种了
这本还有一种游戏是什么呢
叫荒也求生游戏
这是荒原什么东西都没有建好
一片空白
这个时候好的人都可以来
来这个跑马全定
全的人多了
这开始有争证了这时候怎么办
这个时候就制定规则
有的人就成了规则的制定者
对吧
你说以哪一类游戏
所以各位现在你思考一下
你到底玩的是哪一类游戏
你属于这个游戏底的什么样的一个身份
好了现在各位
我来说一下我们大多数人的问题
我们大多数人是玩的一款成帮游戏
就是规则已经制定好了
对吧
然后呢
属于什么身份呢
属于游戏的尊重者
所以我说了我不上一回法软件
我反而让你一定要
不要违法软件
但是我们可能属于
这两个身份这个身份之后的话
还有三个知名的问题
我给你花花相和
我们很多人是这个样子
他要求一个确定性
好我要稳定
我要稳定
我为什么做这个事呢
你没做稳定啊
对吧我们选择一件事首先是稳定
是有确定的性的
第二
做什么事一定要有正确答
我有了正确答案才做
如果没有正确答案我是不做的
在恶惹这些答案
你三个的话呢
一定要
要旁边人的周围人的人的认同
哎呀我
我看这个事我们家里面就看了怎么办
我们领导看怎么办
我朋友看了怎么办
所以我给坏一下我们很多人这样子
再玩一款成帮游戏
游戏都已经制定好了
您属于游戏规测的制定者
我刚才说了
就这么多人强一块地
谁
谁能强那个那个帝呢
对吧
不是最有实力的人哦
是什么人啊
是最懂
游戏规测的人
最善于的拥游戏规的人
拥有游戏规测体也是喘的人
或者是交感游戏规测的人
你是属于那个游戏规测的尊重者
企业
要求确定性
要求正确答案就把正直外包了
我还怎么做才行啊
企业
要求身边的人认同
开枪玩这个游戏的时候获得最大力
你在想什么
你在这种情况下
获得最大力只有一种情况
叫燈刺
那么是不是我们可能就没有机会了
要有机会
一个方法是什么
就是离开成邦
去寻找一个
豐富的天员什么叫豐富的天员啊
获联网刚出来的时候
任何一个新技术刚出来的时候
一种过来往刚出来的时候
短视频刚出来的时候
AI刚出来的时候
这个时候你会发现
还没有规则
谁也不知道它是个傻
所以各位你看明白了吗
存在
红利存在机会的地方
不是确定的地方
反而是
谁也不知道它是傻的时候
一片荒无
看起来就
就乱七八糟的
这个时候是最好的实际
那么这个时候就有一些人啊
对吧
比如说
拥有任职差的信息差的人
就是他最先知道的人
比如说
你不知道小龙小的时候我知道
然后我可以告诉你们
你看我可以获得一下
对不对
第二个是什么呢
第二个是拥有任职差的人
哇
这个时候就不太一样了
任职差是什么
任职差是
一个新事物来的时候
没有人知道它是什么
但这有人能想明白它是什么
在吧
比如说
有人认为它是流量
有人认为它是娱乐
有人认为它是现任被输
对不对你看就
比如说有人去土地上去了以后干嘛
去了以后它是认为
这个地方我就结略结略一下
就像过去的凶努一下
结略一下 结了 结了完走了
还有人是干嘛 我要成这个地方是我的
还有人是这个地方不是我的
都是你们的
但是我是攻击者的执行者
我们说到短视频那个时候就会另一次就好了
因为想那个就太复杂了
有人认为短视频是娱乐
所以它短视频出来的时候第一件事情干嘛
现代不玩
我要把我的经历
赚住在我的什么什么什么什么
反正也行吧
但是当机会来的那时候它就错过了
还有那人的话短视频是流量
所以它叫会
把它的用插上流量的吃
对吧 但确实是什么的流量
它一定是我红密的
我刚才说了 都跑马权地
都来了
慢慢就要挥择了
这个时候红力就消失了 红力消失的时候
华尔流量的人就慢慢就没有了
就退伤了 所以你看很多网红
它只能活几岸
那么它不然不是几个会
只能资论几年
对不对
还有一个人是认为这是一个信任背书的好地方
信任背书的好地方
这个时候你发现哪怕红力没有了 对不起
它认识人存在 它认识人想收复理
所以各位 你说你哪一种呢
那么广有认知还是不够的
这个时候要去行动了
怎么就行动 对吧
因为你的认知觉得能来行动吗
一个地方还是空地的
这个时候很容易
还就开始进来了
跑马权地的 很多人就割一般就走了
很多人要在这个地方
重装你的
很多人要在这个地方留下自己的痕跡的
所以你看
为什么一开始
比如胡脸网来的时候
你用胡脸网来说
很多人跑马权地
走投资的干嘛呀
因为这个时候没有规则
谁也不知道规则是什么
所以说不清楚什么
网网这个时候就是过来俗的跑马权地
这个时候开始人来了
来了以后的话
怎么 你也想要这一块
第一个 我也想要这一块
来吧 坐下来谈一谈吧
咱们不能打架啊 对吧
谈一谈吧
你看有些人就很聪明
这个地方比较围一强
但是我要飞一些给你
飞一个女孩我做得很低达吧
对吧 我是怎么做的
我是怎么做的
对不对
这个时候就能服众
就会有伤锅一啊
大家就写场一块来的
们做一样
那有的时候要打架了
什么监管就进来了
你看 你们做的不错
你们做的不错
你的那个方法
就变成了孤独
归此
归此是治后的兄弟们
能不能要意思吗
你在体会一下刚才我说的事情
什么什么赚钱的事
写的什么什么
你开始什么玩笑
规则是治后的
然后
这个时候你没法想
你反而成为了
规则游戏规则的制定了
你们干什么事
都要符合我的标准
我制定了
USB就会的标准了
我制定了什么什么的标准
对吧
我有专利干什么是有我的平台
只要用我的平台上
下软件就带给我
就要30%的飞
只要你要怎么怎么样
对不对
这就变成了什么
我是游戏规则制定制
所以你看我们
为什么很多人
他做不了的
对吧
各位好好想一想
对不对
我们很多人是
再玩一个成帮的东西
然后又是游戏的尊重者
对不对
然后一个新游戏才来的时候
看不起
小伙伤
因为刚开始来的时候
什么都不知道
慌复的土地随便去
看不起小伙伤
然后人跑过圈地了
然后这个地方发展起来
我靠来不及
而且就是我们为什么
就是我们很多人的画象
最终确定最终穩定
最终确大
最终别人的人口
就很难发展起来
所以各位
你真正要做的
不是以后
稳定的确定的正确的
相反你要尋找的是那个
不确定的
还没有正确
把闷的问题